SEPARATION H
THIS IS AN AERIAL ASSAULT NOW,
LOOK AT STARS GAME
RIGHT BEFORE THEM.
>> TOWN ONEN MOTIVATION.
HIS FACS
BEEN OUT.
>> WHY DON'T YOU TELL US.
>> ZERO. TIP-IN.
HE'S NOT GOING TO LEAVE ANYTHING
UP TO QWIGGINS, BATTLING
ANTHONY. OF
BOUNDS.
THE HAMMER DOWN. THE HAMMER.
AND THE ALLSTATE THREES.
AND THEY CASH IN AT THE SOME NI
AND DEREK WHITE STEPPING UP AND
TAKING
KNICKS BACK UP 17.
>>>>
REEL DUNK
BECAUSE HE SEES .
CADE.
GOOD FEED!
BAGLEY! MOVE.
NOW, HE JUST HIT A ON
TWO THE OTHER WAY, W
THE BENCH, HE KNEW THAT
OF COURSE WHEN MELTON IS
SHOOTING THIS WELL,  ----THE WA
OF THAT ONE HAND TRAIN COMING
DOWN THE LANE.  NIGHT!
SUNS TURN THEM OVER AGAIN.
BOOKER SCO.3-POINT SHOT.>>
BRING IN THIS CROWD  THE DORM S.
THE IT ON THE DECK.
ON KARL.
HE WAS THERE, KARL WN'T PLAY AR.
I L